[Musique]
et sur le site historique de la
conserver royal brobo société que la
famille leroy racheter en 85 à la
famille 2009
venez je vais vous raconter cette
histoire c'est de l'histoire de deux
voyages bourbon donc un site qui est
aujourd'hui en friche et qui a
fonctionné à peu prés jusqu'aux années
c'est bâtiment chargé d'histoire puisque
à l'origine c'était une préparation de
verdi et c'est ensuite devenu une
conserver je vois tout toute l'histoire
de la réunion et l'histoire industrielle
de la réunion depuis la
départementalisation
on est sur le site historique de la
conserverie de villeneuve donc a été
créée en 1949 à l'origine donc pour
transformer conserver les produits
agricoles de l'exploitation puisque
on fabriquait aussi bien des achats
palmistes et des pales de piment que des
conserves de bichiques en boîte souvient
surtout des bichiques et des paniers de
bichiques que ont récupéré sur le board
les berges de la rivière des roches
aujourd'hui à plus de bichiques au
démarrage de la départementalisation est
pratiquement jusqu'à à 1981 date de la
mise en place du rmi
nous étions quand même dans une
situation où beaucoup de réunionnais
ne mangez pas à leur faim et les
inégalités très forte
donc il y avait une population quand
même qui était un peu un peu démunis et
surtout dans une situation de précarité
très forte
nous on a démarré avec ce qu'on appelle
la vente à la chine c'est de se dire la
camionnette qu'on charge et le matin et
on faisait la tournée des boutiques
chinois et on va en vendée on encaissait
tout de suite et nous sommes passés
d'une d'une société où il y avait une
précarité et très peu d'offres à une
société pléthorique avec une offre
gigantesque
il a fallu que des entreprises
réunionnaises trouve trouvent leur place
dans ce monde qui était réservé à
l'implantation pendant pendant de
nombreuses années
[Musique]
on rachète la société en 84 trois cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires et 4
personnes et aujourd'hui on est
plus de 20 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires et on est à 140 personnes 350
mille boîtes à peu près vendus par mois
ça fait vraiment partie de la culture
pearl les conserves de haricots et nous
on a su accompagner la ménagère
réunionnaise suis hors une facilitation
de la cuisine avec des conserves de
haricots
on est passé d'une dune société on était
repliée sur ce nous mêmes avec un blocus
pendant la guerre on est ensuite arrivé
à une société on a été en lien direct
avec la métropole départementalisation
et ouverture mais essentiellement vers
la france et aujourd'hui on est en train
de vivre une troisième révolution c'est
l'ouverture vers vers l'international
[Musique]